today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so we had the first presidential debate
this week there are still two more
debates uh next week is the vp debate
but then the week after and the week
after that we have debates number
two and three between donald trump and
joe biden and it turns out that donald
trump
so ruined the prospects of having an
actual
debate on tuesday night because of his
constant
petulant interruptions that the
commission on presidential debates
is changing the rules for the debates in
order to allow
an actual adult conversation it's just
stunning they have to
account for donald trump's childish
behavior something which you know it's
much like
the norms that we have established for
presidential conduct
many of them we don't think about what
happens if we have to enforce them
because we imagine we would never have
to
much like that with the debate rules
they now are having to come up with
rules
because donald trump goes above and
beyond what is normal and the commission
on presidential debates has now said
quote
last night's debate made clear that
additional structure
should be added to the format of the
remaining debates to ensure a more
orderly discussion of the issues
the commission will be carefully
considering the changes
that it will adopt and will announce
those measures shortly now those
measures have not yet been announced
there's a source close to the commission
which says
they are thinking about giving the
moderator or someone
the ability to cut off silence or mute a
candidate's microphone when they violate
rules like for example when joe biden
was
speaking during his two minutes donald
trump would just keep talking and
talking and talking
the the issue with that as far as we've
been told
is both candidates would need to agree
to it in principle
i can't imagine trump would agree to it
now the commission could always say
the situation is extenuating and we're
putting this with this rule in place
even if you don't agree
and then it would be up to trump to
either bail on the debate or or to go
but i i assume that there's not
too many other tools you can really
think about putting in place
and the reaction from trump campaign
communications director
tim murdoch is to disagree and
he put out a written statement saying
quote they shouldn't be moving the goal
posts and changing the rules in the
middle of the game
moderator chris wallace has been
criticized as if he were the problem
i think you know he did a reasonably
okay job given the tools
that he had but chris wallace says he
doesn't
think muting the microphones would
really solve the problem he said that
quote even if the president's microphone
had been shut
he still could have continued to
interrupt and biden's microphone might
have picked it up
anyway i i do think that although that's
true
if you mute trump's mic and biden is
talking and you hear
trump in the background much more
quietly
that just makes trump look even worse
and and
although chris wallace is right in a
sense i think that that would have been
very very bad if biden is talking and
the camera's on biden
but you sort of hear trump tweeting like
a little bird in the background now
trump's perspective on all of this is
less nuanced less sophisticated
donald trump tweeted quote try getting a
new
anchor and a smarter democrat candidate
they just can't play by the rules trump
can't his family can't they don't play
by the rules in any aspect
of their lives and they're not playing
by the rules here speaking of rules by
the way
you might have seen video of when
trump's family entered the debate hall
melania ivanka etc they were wearing
masks as were the rules of the
the debate hall but then they just took
them off when the debate got started
and uh you know that that's against the
rules they just sat there maskless
everybody else was wearing masks
okay i mean i they just don't follow the
rules and there are no repercussions
now the idea i have for this is sort of
a difficult to manage
idea because it's logistically difficult
but my idea would be
if it's biden's time and trump starts
talking over him
you pause biden's time so he doesn't
lose any time
while while trump is interrupting and
trump's interruptions are deducted from
his next answer so
if trump interrupts for 20 seconds biden
gets an extra 20 seconds
and in his next answer trump loses 20
seconds it's very hard to manage in real
time
trump would absolutely lose his mind
they would cry about fake news
everybody's against them all of this
stuff
but that's really the only idea i can
think of which is
if you can't stop trump from talking but
you can say
we have a total amount of speaking time
here and any that you use now you don't
get to use later
it's an idea if you have a better one
certainly let me know
now if you want something approximating
substantive discussion here
i believe the only real chance at that
is the vice presidential debate next
week
vice presidential nominee kamala harris
will be facing off wednesday evening
against vice president mike pence
i believe she's going to crush him i i
think it's going to be
just a brutal brutal slaughtering of
mike pence by kamal harris
but let's watch it together we will be
streaming wednesday evening
live on youtube twitch and facebook
i invite you to join me i think it will
be very interesting and maybe we will
actually get
some policy discussion which would be
interesting for a change
one of the things that was suggested
during the first presidential debate
by donald trump was that trump suggested
his supporters
go to the polls and observe
what's going on hang out at polling
places see if things look okay
now as i mentioned if you there are poll
workers
and there are poll volunteers you can't
just
show up and volunteer on the day of you
have to actually sign up to do that
if you just show up and you're quote
observing and you're you're essentially
loitering in some states that's against
the law and it's voter intimidation
and nevada's attorney general is not
taking this lightly and has said if you
do what trump is suggesting
we will arrest you and we will prosecute
you because it is in nevada illegal
let's start with a reminder about what
donald trump said
about this tuesday night at the debate
but it is so i
first for you sir finally for the for
the vice president i hope neither of you
will interrupt the other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump you're going forcing my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen i am
urging them to do it as you know today
there was a big problem
in philadelphia they went in to watch
they were called poll watchers a very
safe very nice thing
they were thrown out they weren't
allowed to watch you know why
because bad things happen in
philadelphia bad things
so the reason trump's poll watchers were
thrown
out is that they weren't actually poll
watchers there's a process
if you want to be a volunteer you have
to actually
sign up typically it's run at the county
level but you'd have to see how it is in
your your city state or municipality
you don't just show up or show up armed
as someone who is there to observe the
way donald trump is suggesting it's not
going to do
it's voter intimidation to hang out all
day at polls without being an actual
volunteer
who signed up and is on a list of
someone who's going to be there to do
that and trump is encouraging that
trump is encouraging voter intimidation
and it shouldn't surprise us trump
encouraged
try to vote twice that's a felony in
some places including north carolina
trump has encouraged all sorts of
behavior that is either
immoral or illegal in some cases and
nevada's attorney general says
we will prosecute people who do this if
you do this we will prosecute prosecute
you
if you follow donald trump's advice and
you go to polling places and you
monitor votes being cast or counted uh
it is voter intimidation aaron ford
tweeted quote
trump also told his supporters
to go into the polls and watch very
carefully
but he wasn't talking about poll
watching he was talking about voter
intimidation
for your information voter intimidation
is illegal in nevada
believe me when i say it you do it and
you will be prosecuted
now to follow up on trump's claim
that some injustice has transpired
because his fans who showed up in philly
weren't allowed in
we looked into it legitimate poll
officers
and volunteers in philadelphia have been
able to do their jobs
but you have to actually be there in an
official capacity
random people who show up and say i'm
gonna watch
aren't actually part of anything they
can't hang out
intimidating people that's not i was
gonna say it's not how our democracy
works
it's not how our democracy is supposed
to work
now for you what to do if you
see funny business when you go to vote
three things to keep in mind number one
you can report voter intimidation to the
aclu
by calling 866 hour vote put it in your
phone
number two you can report voter
intimidation
or electioneering or whatever to the
local county elections board
again most elections are run at the
county level that's why we get results
county by county often on election night
google the phone number
for your county elections board put it
in your phone before you go
you can safe if you can safely and
legally get video of what's going on
send it to me
i will do everything i can to send it to
my media contacts and to publicize it on
this program
this applies to early voting the
supplies on election day we will be
standing by on election day
uh to hear from you if funny business is
going on it's also
important for people to know what is and
is not permitted in their jurisdiction
so there's a brief summary of poll
watcher laws
available uh we're linking to a website
that has that summary
in the description to this youtube clip
so you've got it or you can just google
uh poll watcher laws massachusetts poll
watcher laws louisiana or whatever state
you live in so like as an example in new
york
each party can have three poll watchers
present
and the poll watchers can challenge your
right to vote when you appear at the
polling place
but it would not override any
anti-discrimination laws if they're
challenging every black voter
or disproportionately black voters that
wouldn't be okay
you know enforcing it in the heat of
election day is another question
it also never permits harassment
intimidation coercion electioneering
trying to either prevent someone from
voting or influencing vote so that's new
york
understand the laws in your state and
yeah
it's tragic that this is how we have to
prepare
to go and vote uh my plan for now
um is i i do have an absentee ballot
coming
and if it gets to me reasonably soon i
don't know when massachusetts is sending
them out i
i would fill it out and drop it off
personally
um otherwise i might avail myself of the
early voting that takes place
uh in massachusetts that's my thought
let me know
your plan uh i'm on twitter at d pacman
and remember
that if you prefer a long-form audio
podcast
each day rather than short youtube clips
or facebook video clips
you can find our audio podcast just
about on any podcast platform
itunes stitcher spotify
so on and so forth uh uh find us there
let me know your voting plan
on twitter at dpakman and we will be
right back
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that membership is our primary
funding source
i invite you to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code
2020 now all one word all lowercase 2020
now to save 66
if you could imagine that is a discount
that is
certainly immoral and sometimes illegal
depending where you live it's too big of
a discount grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
i was browsing the david pakman show
subreddit this morning
at davidpakman.com slash reddit that's
r-e-d-d-i-t um and i saw
a post called what the hell is wrong
with you americans
which says i mean seriously last night's
debates
wouldn't even be normal in turkmenistan
that's an
insult to the turkmenis uh what the hell
happened to you people
you used to be the amazing people now
you were looking at two geriatric
rapists snarling half-finished sentences
and blatant lies to each other what the
hell happened
i i reject the characterization of two
geriatric rapists it seems like maybe
you've fallen
for some uh unconfirmed conspiracy
theories there or
or or what whatever the case may be but
uh dozens of emails like that coming in
from all over the world
what is wrong with you people even if
trump loses as i've been saying
how are 60 million of you voting for
this guy
and this is a reality we have to contend
with the
world at one point maybe they were
laughing
they are shocked the rest of the world
is disgusted the rest of the world
pities us the rest of the world is
concerned
because we have more than 60 million
people here who not only
voted for trump but they're going to do
it again
another user on the subreddit nerdlinger
says is anybody else not even surprised
that people are defending trump's
performance yesterday blaming chris
wallace accusing biden of having an
earpiece
playing the both sides game as if both
candidates were completely unhinged last
night
acting offended over biden calling trump
a clown
proud boys aren't white nationalists i
figured this would happen if trump gave
the most indefensible appearance
possible and he did
and i'm not at all surprised really i
feel so desensitized to this stuff now
david really needs to do a good long
episode on
long-term implications of trumpism
um yeah i i mean we knew
listen every debate every year every
election cycle
each side claims they won trump claims
he won biden claims he won
um in in reality uh what really matters
is how the the relatively few and far
between
undecided voters see it
because trump's base is already voting
for trump the anti-trump people are
already
voting for joe biden so it's not really
surprising
that the trump base is defending trump's
performance
but you were right about the unfortunate
reality
as i said just because of the last uh
reddit post
um even if trump loses what happens with
trump-ism and i think that there is a
real risk that if donald trump gets
re-elected
it's not just four more years of trump
it bolsters the possibility of one of
the trump
children running in 2024
and things get even uglier if you can
imagine that
last notable post from the subreddit
from user
genius of slaughter who says trump
saying he would run the country like his
business
is the only true thing he's ever said
look at trump's tax returns man so
inspirational
yet can can we put to bed this idea
that we need a business person president
this is something that we heard when
mitt romney was running in 2012
and at the time the question was what
example do we have
of a businessman turned president that
did really well and there there were no
examples
we now have a supposed businessman
turned president and it's been an
unmitigated and total disaster
uh so so we we need to stop with that
and in fact i would love to see
presidents come
from other backgrounds altogether what
about a scientist
president what about a president with a
background in education
uh or philosophy as an example or or
maybe even economics i know
you know some some maybe wouldn't like
that but we we actually have a problem
where
the scope of where presidents come from
is too narrow
uh and and i think we would be uh far
better served
to expand it in other directions than
businessman president
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit so we got our first look at a
post
debate trump yesterday of course the
debate with joe biden
took place tuesday night it did not go
well for donald trump but to be fair
it might have gone well enough for him
to keep his existing support i don't
think his base will abandon him based on
the outrageous and childish performance
of tuesday night
in fact his base thinks that he won so
it may not really move the needle
very much but what i was interested in
was what is trump's state of mind what
is trump's demeanor
post debate we saw him tweeting unhinged
things but he did another one of these
corona rallies last night
this one was in duluth minnesota and
trump spent
a bunch of time recently in minnesota
where currently joe biden leads
by more than nine points in recent
polling donald trump has been insisting
he might win minnesota
i doubt it but he's spending some time
there
the rally was really really sick i i was
sort of paying special attention to what
trump would say
about the debate itself whether he'd
scale up his attacks on joe biden to be
even nastier ad hominems
but he also said all sorts of other
things that are of course
untrue and in many cases completely
disgusting so let's look at it a little
bit donald trump launched
directly into straight up lies by just
making things up whole cloth
he said joe biden is trying to cancel
the remaining debates
biden has not suggested canceling the
remaining debates
biden has not asked for a cancellation
biden has not dropped out but donald
trump doesn't care
he says it and the crowd believes it is
too weak to leave this country
you know biden lost badly when his
supporters are saying he should cancel
the rest of the debates
now i understand he's cancelling the
debates let's see what happens i think
that's not going to be a good move
i don't think that's going to be a good
move on the television with those
ratings they're never going to let them
cancel you don't know television like
that
this is how nonsense spreads trump tells
a crowd
biden's cancelling debates the crowd
goes goes home and posts on facebook
biden is canceling the debates someone
makes a meme biden is canceling the
debates and before you know it
there's this false notion spreading that
biden has canceled the remaining debates
and has backed out completely untrue
donald trump again told this story that
he's been telling
about how there was a day i guess it
must have been about a month ago
trump tells the story where he went home
to melania and he asked
darling did you see the news on tv about
my nobel peace prize nomination
and melania this is the story says to
him no i didn't see it
they they were talking about a hurricane
and this time trump adds the really
dismissive wrinkle
of saying they were talking about rain
now of course
rain was the hurricane that was
devastating florida
destroying people's homes destroying
people's lives and trump says
they covered rain instead of my nobel
peace prize nomination
but i told my first lady i told her
first lady
darling you're going to be so proud of
me tonight we're going to watch
television
and you're not going to believe how big
this goes what happened what happened
darling i won the i was nominated for
the nobel peace prize
for israel right bahrain
united arab emirates and then again
again i was nominated again
for serbia kosovo all different then i
was nominated a third time but i said
first time
second time i was a little bit yeah i
know i love you too
but i said to our first lady watch
this tonight darling it's going to be
and i turned to lester holt number two
show
i turned to lester holt and they covered
one star was about reign
this is just it's the height of
narcissism isn't it
how dare the news cover a hurricane
wreaking havoc
they should be talking about how a
norwegian right-winger or was it a
finnish or swedish
some northern european right winger said
i should get the nobel peace prize isn't
that the story
instead of a hurricane destroying
people's lives
the unabashed height of narcissism
donald trump then mocked joe biden
because joe biden takes coronavirus
seriously and joe
biden doesn't want to do events for his
campaign
that risk the spread of coronavirus not
a concern
trump has but trump ridicules joe biden
for it
i don't know how many are involved this
was supposed to be an iron range get
together
but it turns out big you know biden has
20 30 people he's got those circles
today he had a little bit more like 30
or 40 but they were too close together i
sent him a note
dear joe they were too close 34 people
right next to each other
and yet he complained about our rally
right our rallies
now it's an honor that so many people
showed up because this was going to be a
little quickie just to say
congratulations
because obama closed the iron range
imagine
making fun of the candidate that's
taking the public health precautions
during a global hundred year pandemic
that
you mishandled read leading now to 211
000 deaths
far more than what we needed to have
backwards
bizarro world in this next clip donald
trump tells
a completely implausible story including
what we call the sir routine okay now
the sir routine
is when trump tells a story of someone
saying something to him he will often
say
they said to me sir etc
uh and this time it's about a guy who
supposedly came to trump
so overwhelmed with emotion about how
trump had improved this guy's life
that the guy was crying i mean it's a
completely incredible story take a
listen
a man came up to me a tough man a man
who
a worker a construction worker real
worker
and he looked at me this is two years
ago he said sir
you've given us back our life and he was
crying
and i said when was the last time you
cried he said i can't remember i said
you never cried
when you were a little baby you never
cried this is not a crier this guy was
tough as hell
he said sir he took our our life away
and let me tell you about joe joe will
reinstitute that ban in two minutes if
we lucy you better vote for me in
minnesota really i mean honestly
imagine being a fly on the wall during
that meeting
between trump and this guy if it even
took place
also this dumb idea that crying is the
opposite of toughness
just every lame trope that trump
can't seem to get away from and then
here we have just a simple lie
donald trump says he says this in every
state every time
he goes to pennsylvania he goes to north
carolina trump will always say
you had your best year last year you had
your best years
during my presidency and of course he
says it to minnesota here
the story with jason but let's do it
anyway
but we're going to win so much because
minnesota before i came around was not
doing too well
okay was not doing too well then you had
your best years ever
now the truth is a little different the
unemployment rate in minnesota
is now 94 percent higher
than when donald trump took office the
unemployment rate in minnesota was 3.8
in january of 2017. it is currently 7.4
and that's down by the way from its
coronavirus high so
just a simple lie and a simple fact
check how quaint right it's sort of like
the old days of politics
trump continuing to be obsessed with the
suburbs lately donald trump ridiculously
and laughably claims here again
that joe biden will destroy the suburbs
by abolishing single-family zoning
well whether we allow joe biden to kill
the recovery you know he wants a
shutdown this guy says let's shut it
down
a lot of death caused by shutdown
depression
death drugs alcoholism
horrendous family fights horrendous
family fights
and he wants to destroy those suburbs by
abolishing
single-family zoning all of these things
are just a horrible thing
what he wants to do it is stunning how
saying localities should look at the
racial
impact of zoning became biden wants to
end
the suburbs and now it's biden will
eliminate all single-family zoning
it just just completely disconnected
from reality and the crowd now because
trump has been repeating it for so long
they're used to it they anticipate it
they cheer or boo or whatever reaction
it is that donald trump wants
and then trump uh continuing with this
suburb
obsession trump admonishes the crowd and
he says how the hell am i not doing well
in the suburbs
you know they talk about the suburbs
women in the suburbs
i ended a regulation that nobody would
have done
this brings public housing low-income
housing into the suburbs and by the way
just so we can get this right
30 of the people in the suburbs
are low-income people 30 percent of the
people in the suburbs are minorities
and so we're ruining this american dream
for everybody but he's got
a plan it's the worst thing you've ever
seen having to do with zoning
they zone you out they build low income
housing next to your house
it's crazy and then i hear i'm not doing
well in the suburbs
i'm not doing well in the suburbs are
you people crazy
are you crazy that's uh it's an unusual
way
to get the crowd on your side isn't it
it's a strange way to
win votes to say what the hell is wrong
with you people
maybe it works for the average trump
supporter i i really don't pretend to
know at this point
what the average trump supporter wants
to hear from donald trump
but the rallies continue and post-debate
trump
as unhinged as ever no rally on today's
calendar for donald trump upcoming
includes next week's
vice presidential debate on wednesday
which we will be broadcasting live on
youtube
twitch and facebook the week after that
is vice is a presidential debate number
two the week after that
is presidential debate number three
we've got a one-week respite from the
debates
and then it's election day that's it
folks so we've got vp
debate on week one trump debate week two
trump biden debate week three week four
is off
week five is the election and that's it
okay this is the final stretch
later on in the program we are going to
talk about some of the
sort of desperate measures that the
trump campaign
is taking tomorrow we will be talking
about incredible fundraising
by joe biden during the debate record
fundraising
and we will of course have continued
coverage of all of this
and more on the david pakman show
instagram page make sure you're
following us on instagram
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
program today dr pineal
joseph who's the founding director of
the center for the study of race and
democracy
professor of history at the university
of texas at austin
also author of the book the sword and
the shield the revolutionary lives of
malcolm x and martin luther king jr
so great to have you on thank you for
having me david
so to begin with uh we've seen
over the last four to six months some of
the
larger protests that this country has
seen
uh i guess we can say in in the sort of
medium term
since the occupy wall street days of
some years ago
and one of the great debates that has
surfaced
is in the context of the teachings of
malcolm x
and the teachings of martin luther king
what would they
say about the protests today
what would their views be about the
tactics
that would be considered either valid or
moral or productive for achieving change
today uh and and my instinct is
that a lot of people uh are ascribing to
these two men
what they already believe to be the
right answer and so i i want to start by
going back to the history
where can how can we frame this
conversation
well i think the best way to frame it is
to look at the convergences
between malcolm x and martin luther king
jr
so even though we think of malcolm as
the political sword
of the 1960s and we think of king as
sort of this non-violent human rights
shield
one of the things i argue in my new book
is that they really converge
malcolm x is arguing for radical black
dignity king is arguing for radical
black citizenship
and over time they come to use that
political sword
and shield malcolm x
goes from talking about self-defense and
certainly this global revolution
to saying that the civil rights movement
should be a human rights movement
and he talks about the ballot or the
bullet and actually you did
using voting rights and using democratic
institutions
but he always reserves the right of
indigenous people for self-defense
a king goes from talking about
non-violence
and he's always talking about no use of
violence but he starts to
look at civil disobedience as a tool he
calls it a non-violent political sword
by 1965
that could paralyze cities in order to
achieve racial justice and human rights
for black people but for all people
right so when we think about
the black lives matter movement what
that movement does is
it uses both king's notion of radical
black citizenship
and malcolm x's notion of radical black
dignity and when you think about what
did malcolm mean by that
he meant eradicating systemic racism and
defeating white supremacy globally
and allowing black people to have
political self-determination
king is going to say that citizenship is
more than voting rights
it's actually a right to an income
a guaranteed job affordable housing king
talks about food justice and of course
dies trying to lead a poor people's
campaign
um to occupy washington dc david
so you mentioned occupy wall street but
king tried to occupy washington dc in
1968
one of the things in in the last six
months looking at interviews
from decades ago but with both malcolm x
and martin luther king
one of the refrains that i frequently
heard from martin luther king that
i didn't find malcolm x using and i'm
curious whether it is it is actually a
distinction or maybe i didn't look hard
enough
was martin luther king asserting that
one of the risks sometimes of going over
into
violence is that it ends up
disproportionately hurting the very
people who these
movements are actually trying to help so
sort of a two-part question is it true
that that is a difference and that we
did not hear that
specific idea from malcolm x and is it
is it accurate
well i say that malcolm talks about even
stephen
he talks about an eye for an eye i think
when we think about malcolm x
uh he talks about the mao mao what
happened in kenya
he's really thinking about and
supporting anti-colonial movements
anti-imperialist movements um he
supports the cuban revolution
he supports the algerian revolution he's
supporting revolutions all over the
place
um so he's not saying exactly what king
says there where look if we were to
achieve
uh or try to enact guerrilla warfare
we're gonna suffer the disproportionate
losses
um which i think king is correct in in
saying i think malcolm is more thinking
about this global
political revolution and remember
malcolm's alive
during the age where africa is
decolonizing
where uh latin america and the caribbean
and south america this is you think
about from the 1940s all the way into
the 80s and the 90s
the world is really on fire right the
last african country is going to be
south africa with the freedom of nelson
mandela
but when we think about central america
latin america the caribbean
there are still battles being waged when
we think about nicaragua
when we when we think about el salvador
when we think about the world the world
continues
to brazil and different parts of south
america there continues to be
unrest and upheaval where indigenous
people are arguing for the right for
what
political self-determination and
liberation and freedom
so malcolm's always on that side i do
think what we'll see
where they really converge by 1964 is
that malcolm he takes his hajj
to mecca and remember malcolm is a part
of this global islamic community right
malcolm was always a muslim
whether he's in the nation of islam or
he takes the hajj
but he starts to say that sincere whites
can be part of the movement right
if whites are willing to give up uh
white privilege and racism
they can be part of this movement which
he calls a global human rights movement
and he also says this
this at oxford university david in 1964
one of the best debates and the bbc
carries this uh
this debate where malcolm receives a
standing ovation he does a 30-minute
debate
and he's actually it's this is very this
is an interesting historical nugget
he's actually defending barry
goldwater's phrase extremism
in defense of liberty is no vice but for
different ideological reasons than barry
goldwater right barry goldwater
is a conservative hero of the american
right and he
used that term to defend racial
segregation
malcolm used the term extremism in
defense of liberty
is no vice to defend his adam
his adage of by any means necessary
liberation
by any means necessary freedom uh
citizenship by any means necessary and
he tells the
students multiracial audience at oxford
university
he says that he's willing to align with
any person
no matter what the color of their skin
as long as they want to
end the miserable condition on the face
of this earth
now i always found those words very very
profound for malcolm
because you can see just the evolution
you see the evolution with king
king becomes this man on fire the last
three years of his life i mean
he's an anti-imperialist he's a radical
he becomes a revolution
revolutionary where he breaks with the
johnson administration the riverside
church speech april 4th 1967 in new york
king says that the united states of
america is the greatest purveyor of
violence in the world
and he's he says there comes a time when
silence is betrayal david
and he says that it's going to be a
bitter but beautiful struggle
and he criticizes the united states he
says people told me to be non-violent in
selma
and when i say be non-violent in hanoi
and they're bombing and they're
they're putting napalm on children on
children
they say that i'm anti-american so he
tells us that the three
biggest evils facing humanity are
militarism
racism and materialism so king is this
extraordinary figure
and king by 67 is always also saying
that
rioting is the language of the unheard
of the oppressed
so everybody who's saying that right now
dr king
would be anti-blm or anti-these protests
they have it exactly wrong dr king said
the roots
of unrest and chaos in the united states
were based on
white supremacy and poverty he says it
to the kerner commission
in october of 1967 he says it
uh during a southern christian
leadership conference
uh a keynote speech where he says the
halls of the u.s congress are running
wild with racism
he says it before a speech to the
american psychological association where
he says
the biggest threat to american democracy
is white violence and white chaos and
white people are hypocritically saying
that
if there was peace there could be racial
progress
but they are the origins of the chaos
in watts in detroit everywhere in terms
of police brutality
poverty racial segregation so we think
about king king is not this
milk toast nice guy who's giving people
hugs
he's a non-violent revolutionary and we
stop
king our memory national memory it stops
with selma
or sometimes stops in 63 with the march
on washington
because we don't want to face the
revolutionary king so
clearly the some of the stories that we
we are told about both malcolm x and
martin luther king
are certainly oversimplified and maybe
one note when the reality is is more
complicated
i want to go back to something you said
you talked about the
the the sort of uh guidelines that
malcolm x expressed about
what in what way can white folks
credibly be be part of the movement and
i'm really interested in that because
the the general question i want to ask
you is
what do you believe the views of these
two men would be
about modern identity politics and the
view i've expressed before
is that on the one hand using identity
as either a cudgel
or a way to silence people uh
i think is is is a disaster an example
that i've pointed out was the way in
which
the women's march leadership kept out
jewish women because they were not
intersectional enough in the right way
i'm very much against that
on the other hand our identity informs
our experience
and of course we should be paying
particular attention
to what one's experience has to say
about
solving a particular problem and i think
that that's where the right goes wrong
in this kind of umbrella denunciation of
identity as even something relevant to
talk about so
all of that being said what how would
these two men malcolm x and martin
luther
king view what in in today's uh language
is called identity politics
yeah i think that they would be
supportive but they would want nuance to
it right so
uh malcolm martin people like james
baldwin and here's where you know i
probably would say when we think about
identity politics david
historically there's always been
identity politics in the united states
it's just that they were based on
cisgender white male wasps
who were very very rich which by the way
still exists
in some movements on the american right
like the tea party movement and others
absolutely yeah so they these these
these things in a de facto way and
sometimes in a very vicious way were
anti-semitic
anti-black anti-woman anti-people of
color
anti-folks who are non-cisgender who are
lgbtqia so we we have to say that
and what we did with that original
identity politics david is that we said
that
was universal that was the universality
that
identity whether it's washington or
jefferson was the key
to the world to unlock human potential
and that's why when we would read
faulkner
or walt whitman you think shakespeare
you're not
necessarily even reading stuff by white
women when you thought what the classics
were right
you're not reading stuff by jews you're
not reading stuff by muslims
you're not reading stuff by black people
so we have to say the original but
the original identity politics has
everything to do with race but it's
it's a white supremacist very elitist
classist heteronormative identity
politics
we're going to pause our conversation
with dr pineal joseph there the full
interview and it is extensive will be
available on my youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this is something i didn't end up
having time for earlier this week but i
did want to get to it because it's a
preview of what we can expect next week
in the vice presidential debate
between kamala harris and vice president
mike pence
when the trump tax story broke we
learned
thanks to the new york times that trump
paid no federal taxes in 10 of the last
15 years
paid only 750 total in federal taxes in
2016 and in 2017 but we also learned
about donald trump's debts and we talked
about these earlier in the week
300 million dollars in loans that come
due during what would be trump's second
presidential term if he gets one
420 million dollars in total debt likely
1.1 billion in total debt if you include
other debts and and uh which we outlined
earlier in the week
joe biden's vice presidential nominee
kamala harris
california democratic senator went on
msnbc's lawrence o'donnell program
and pointed out the real threat of trump
owing people money take a look at this
video clip
florence this is why the american people
deserve to have a full accounting
of the financial interest including the
indebtedness
of the president of the united states
and i and i do share in that concern
who does he owe the money to tell us who
do you owe the money to
we need to know that the american people
have a right to know that when the
president of the united states acts
he acts with their priorities in mind
not with his priorities in mind of
course
later on this was clarified including in
our segments
about it yesterday donald trump's debts
are a national security risk we talked
about that now kamala harris was slammed
by some people
because we do know about some of donald
trump's debts
and some of donald trump's debts are to
banks that are household names deutsche
bank
and others those publicly
known and acknowledged debts are not
really the concerning ones those are
often tied to a specific property or a
mortgage and there's
at least relative transparency about
them
the ones that are the big question marks
are the ones that
are from the period 2006 to 2014
and that was a time when donald trump
was spending huge amounts of cash
that he doesn't tend to have as we're
learning
and he spent huge amounts of cash buying
or developing or improving properties
and for a long time there's been a
general question about where the hell
the cash came from and now with the
bombshell new york times story
we only have more questions about where
did the cash come from given how
precarious donald trump's financial
position appears to be
based on the documents that the new york
times obtained when we find out
and as we did previously when we know
that donald trump paid 200 million
dollars in cash
to renovate that turnberry golf course
in scotland
where did 200 million in cash come from
because it doesn't appear that donald
trump had it
and now there is even more skepticism
about it uh trump is claiming hey we
just had 200 million in cash sitting
around but it is extraordinarily
difficult to believe that's the case now
and indeed people who know donald
trump's businesses
and his finances have said there's no
way trump had 200 million in cash
particularly at that time you can check
out
adam davidson's work for the new yorker
as one example of someone who really
understands the finances of trump and
the trump organization
and to be clear we don't know
that these are particularly sketchy
debts
tied to trump's claim of having all this
cash
we just know that at a sort of general
level
it's not believable that trump had this
cash at the
time we don't know where the cash came
from
and we know that trump owes a ton of
money so so it's
it's all of those three things put
together now beyond that
not all of trump's deutsche bank debts
are created equal
there are these deutsche bank debts that
like i said are tied to a specific
mortgage to a specific property
but at some point during that same
period
2006 to 2014 donald trump went in the
direction
of private banking at deutsche bank and
at that point the paper trail starts to
get
shadier and shadowier and we just lack
a lot of information about it so there's
sort of a double bottom line here or two
different bottom lines one bottom line
is now with the revelations of the new
york times bombshell tax story
are there even more questions about
who trump owes money to where he got
outrageous amounts of cash that don't
seem to fit his financial situation
during that period 06 to 14. yeah
absolutely
even more questions about it which raise
even more national security questions in
terms of a trump who could be
could be manipulable or subject to
coercion because of the amount of money
that he owes yes
the second bottom line is is this going
to matter in terms of the 2020 election
i hate to say it particularly with more
time now having passed
since the sunday story i think the
answer is no
i i do not think at this point in time
that donald trump is going to be hurt in
any significant way by the new york
times bombshell tax story and what's
crazy about that is
for years we've been saying
the suspicion is trump pays
no or very little taxes trump's not as
wealthy as he thinks as he claims to be
trump owes a lot of people money it was
all proven true by the new york times
bombshell story
and yet the people who care are mostly
already not voting for donald trump
and the people who are voting for donald
trump aren't going to be influenced by
it either way so as much as it pains me
to say it because of what it says about
the american voting public at this point
and it says something very very
bad and sad i don't think that the tax
story is going to make a difference if
you disagree with me i want to hear from
you
and again as far as debates are
concerned vp debate on wednesday
kamala harris versus mike pence i
predict
there will be uh fewer interruptions
from pence than what we saw from donald
trump
and i expect kamala harris is going to
absolutely hammer on mike pence i'm
actually looking forward to it
not in a car crash way but in an and
actually
we might get some policy discussion sort
of way that'll be next wednesday
hope you'll join me on youtube twitch
and facebook this is a really
unusual thing more than anything the
other day
eric trump one of donald trump's kids
went on fox news and he said he was part
of the lgbtq community
something which certainly has not been
made public if indeed it's what he was
trying to say
and initially the speculation was either
eric misspoke
there was some weird grammatical
ambiguity
or he's saying he's bisexual i guess
let's take a look at the video clip the
content is from fox and friends in a
segment
about supposed lgbtq
trump supporters take a look said in the
new york times and
it talks it's this her her name is chris
she doesn't want to give her last name
because
she says that her colleagues at work it
wouldn't go well with them
she lives in manhattan she's in her 50s
secret trump voter
that's right she is she's gay she said
her 401k went up
with your dad 19.6 gas prices
uh better than they were under obama she
goes on to say that obamacare
was 560 a month for her and she had lost
her job so
she was priced out she talks about crime
in the neighborhood she talks about bill
de blasio
and how he's uh inept that the russia
trump russia thing the clinton's
fingerprints are all over it
she calls joe biden week is this but she
doesn't want to use her last name
and there are a lot of people that might
be voting for your dad that aren't
admitting it
and it was brett stevens who's been a
critic of of your
dad who wrote the editorial so are you
counting on this person on the secret
voter
ainslie that person's there i'm telling
you i see it every day the lgbt
community they are incredible and you
should see how they've come out in in
full force for my father every single
day i'm part of that community and we
love the man and thank you for
protecting our neighborhoods and thank
you for
protecting our cities yeah so so eric
trump says he's part of that community
now either he's saying he's bisexual i
guess
or it's some kind of grammatical vagary
he meant something else if we put the
actual word for word quote up on the
screen
what he said was the lgbt community
they are incredible and you should see
how they've come out in full force for
my
father every single day i'm part of that
community
and we love the man so it does
seem that eric trump is saying he is a
member
of the lgbt community that comes out for
his dad
i was thinking is there any other way
you could parse the grammar
and i guess you could maybe say it was
an inarticulate way of eric trump saying
that he's part of the community that
hosts people who come out to support
trump
and that he has been part of hosting
lgbt community member
it would be a very weird grammatical uh
a structure for a native english speaker
but i didn't know what to make of it of
course if eric trump were bisexual i
would have no issue with it whatsoever
but it sort of seemed odd now he put out
a statement eventually clarifying but
before we get to the statement
is it possible that the explanation here
is remember eric trump is not known as
you know the smart one necessarily is it
possible eric trump didn't know what
lgbt meant
like he you know it's uh it's the iwew
union and it's the teamsters and it's
lgbt it like is it actually possible
that eric trump didn't know what lgbt
meant and he was just like yeah i'm part
of it i'm part of it any group that
supports trump i'm actually a part of
is he possibly that dumb i don't know
but eric trump has now backtracked eric
trump put out a statement to the new
york post saying
to clarify many of our close friends
are part of the lgbt community which was
the intent of my statement
the left has taken that vote for granted
for a long time
and support from the gay community for
my father is incredible
as to me personally as i think you know
i am happily
married i am a happily married man
to my wife lara so i still think it's
possible
that in the moment he would have you
give him any four letters
you know abcd or ghyq
whatever he would have said he listened
they support trump i'm part of the
community it's all great maybe he really
didn't know what it meant
it's all just very weird and you
couldn't script
a more bizarre re-election campaign if
you tried we have a voicemail number
that number
is 219 to david p
here is an interesting take about donald
trump's distraction
of joe biden via interruption during the
tuesday night debate take a listen
hi david i listen to you every day i
really enjoy your show
i just have one comment about the debate
if
if trump had been yammering and
screaming and yelling so much at joe
biden
i think joe would have done a lot better
it was hard to concentrate
i'm surprised he didn't lose his focus
more often i mean it was hard just
sitting here listening to it and trying
to keep track of what was going on
so that that's my only remark i just
wondered what you thought about that
i think it's completely plausible that
donald trump with his preconceived
notion
that biden will lose his train of
thought that bidens
uh trump's strategy trump's
interruptions
were not just trump being an unhinged
petulant child but it was the idea that
trump thought if i keep interrupting
it's going to throw joe off his game
and he's going to fall apart now i think
it definitely rattled biden early
but once it became clear that chris
wallace was not going to be able to take
control of it
joe biden figured out what to do and it
included at some point saying
you know will you shut up man you're a
clown and that type of thing
at other points just kind of powering
through trump's interruptions so
i i i do anybody would be distracted by
that if you're trying to speak
coherently about policy as joe biden was
trying to do
and someone's just yammering yammering
and they won't shut up
anybody would get distracted by it i do
think it was a trump strategy and i
think by the second half of the bait
of the debate joe biden better handled
it the commission now says they're going
to change some of the rules
because of trump's interruptions during
the upcoming debates
we will see what those rule changes are
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we have a counter offer
coveted relief bill presented to nancy
pelosi by steven mnuchin we will discuss
it we will talk about the latest bizarre
legal argument being made by tucker
carlson's lawyers
and much more get instant access to the
bonus show
by becoming a member at jointpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video